the jurgen experience
and that's a problem generally that a
lot of people have with the censorship
that's on social media twitter in
particular you know um one of the weird
things that's happening now with uh elon
musk buying twitter
or attempting to buy twitter they've
done something different and one of the
things they've done different is
i gained
now it's 900 000 followers
in the month or so what yes
i mean a lot of people really like you
so maybe nine hundred thousand more
people were like i decided i loved it i
think i was in a box i think it was
megan kelly said the same thing did you
hear her say that she said she gained a
lot she gained a ton like like a hundred
thousand or i'm i don't remember the
number but also a lot like it was really
noticeable and so she was like
she's like i'm pretty sure
twitter was you know
messing yeah around with my account yeah
i think so i think there's something
something was going on i mean i'm just
guessing the other option could be their
bots that i've gained 900 000 bots
but it's it's like every time i look
it's like another hundred thousand it's
crazy it's it it grows faster than
anything and instagram is the opposite
instagram seems to have hit the brakes
on me like sometimes oh yeah somewhere
around six months ago something happened
and it seems like it's it's slowed down
growth a lot i don't check it too much
so i might be wrong it might be you know
i mean maybe it's something they've done
with their algorithm where they uh
prefer videos over photographs now which
i think they do they are they're trying
to go more video i believe because i
read that that's where the viral uh
effect really takes place and i see with
my kids with tick-tock
you have one daughter who's a heavy
tick-tocker oh yeah she's always doing
dancing never been on tick-tock i don't
really understand how you're not 14.
that's true
but little girls
they get together and they do dances and
and they like to like memorize dances
and sync it to music and yeah and then
they're watching all these other people
tick-tocking and doing other these other
and it's like tick-tock just hits you
with video after video after video and
they just get you hooked you open that
app up and it's like you're already like
oh movement things are happening and
this is what they're trying to do i
believe with instagram i think so too
and i i did i've read that i don't get
it because i hate watching videos on
instagram and i hate watching videos on
my phone in general like if i'm gonna
because i'm an old person i guess like
i'm like if i want to watch a video i
want to look at a big screen like i'll
watch stuff on my laptop but i i hate i
don't like reading stuff i don't like
using my phone i don't even like texting
on my phone to be honest like i text on
my laptop
but
i mean i sort of think that instagram
messes with me a little bit too they
refuse to verify my account i've tried
like five times how many flowers do you
have fourteen
thousand
no sorry
is that right
what's the number that you think yeah
who cares
i don't to pretend like i like don't
give a [ __ ] because i do give a [ __ ] but
not that big of a [ __ ]
um
is there a number that you have to reach
before they're they'll verify you oh i
went up to 14.3 k today from
thank you
but i i just felt like my uh my posts
were getting less traction all of a
sudden and they were no different than
what i'd been posting before yeah i
don't know what that is like that could
just be coincidental but i know some
people have definitely been [ __ ] with
and you know there wasn't there a
football player who complained a lot
about it jamie and then eventually he
got let out of instagram why does he
need a like he's a football player like
what does he need an instagram account
i need an instagram account because it's
how i make a living well he does too
that's how you get sponsors when you're
a football player you have to get
sponsorships lots of followers
fine i'm sorry
football player who likes sports what do
you think about it i mean if you have a
large following like a tom brady i mean
god how many sponsors does he have oh
okay you know i mean that's that's an
amazing way to income you don't need an
instagram account to throw a ball you
need it for gatorade and nike and yeah
all the car sponsors and all kinds of
different things when those guys have a
large following that's very valuable
which is really an interesting thing
it's like what is social media for i
mean you're using it for as a business
or using it to be social are you just
having fun and you know expressing
yourself are you using it to
maximize your brand air quotes
i mean i don't brand i swear to god i
don't i'm obviously a very authentic
person i believe i i just i mean i i
have to use social media for work
because i work for myself so it's the
only way i can get what i produce out
into the world and it's the that's how i
make an income almost solely through
individual donations like so people who
send me donations through my website or
they sign up to my patreon
or they pay for a subscription on stack
which i don't i haven't put anything
behind a paywall so you can people can
just choose to pay or not so i just
appreciate it if people pay because
that's how i make an income but like i
don't
have i don't there's no institution
there's nothing kind of pure
yeah and but but i also i would not
really
i don't think i would have a public
instagram account
if i hadn't been but i didn't start a
public instagram account until i was
cooked kicked off of twitter like i have
to do that i don't love spending a bunch
of time on social media do you did you
enjoy twitter though yes yeah i'm like i
don't know why everybody complains about
twitter all the time because i really
liked it i tried to get back on because
i know some people that were banned
before they they try to get back on they
got back on i
i appealed twice since recently yeah
yeah so
since elon musk announced that he was
gonna buy twitter
we'll see if that actually goes through
or not um they just gave into one of his
demands oh did they yeah they just
released uh they we'll see if we can
find what the article says but uh
essentially um he said unless they give
him access to data so he can find out
how many of these accounts are fake
right because his his take on it was
like if you were gonna buy something and
you were buying it under the assumption
that okay here it goes twitter set to
turn bot data over to musk all right so
this says that twitter's board is
reportedly set to pull at about face
offering elon musk internal data on
hundreds of millions of tweets as
advised for the billionaire to complete
his acquisition of the social media
company twitter set to turn over
information to musk capturing more than
500 million tweets the device the post
came from and other information about
the account holders the washington post
reported wednesday citing an unnamed
person familiar with the matter such a
move would help respond to musk's
repeated demands for more information
about the composition of twitter's user
base and the extent of its problem with
bots musk has challenged twitter's
claims that just five percent of its
accounts are bots
calling the way the company calculates
fake accounts very suspicious in a may
tweet
so um i'm really uh interested to see
how this plays out because he is
what he would describe as a free speech
absolutist and i think that that is
something that people are reluctant to
uh to agree
is a good thing because they're worried
about the negative aspects of free
speech you know they're worried about
[ __ ] and you know and and trolls and
all that stuff toughen up man toughen up
and i'm not joking
yeah